lord frost has traveled to brussels
many times to talk about brexit but
rarely has his visit
seemed so pivotal this was a walk with
purpose
he arrived to try to seal a deal with
time rapidly running out
a lot may be riding on this man we're
going to be working very hard to try and
get a deal
we're going to see what happens in
negotiations today and
we will be looking forward to meeting
our european colleagues later on this
afternoon thank you very much fishing
remains a source of contention
france insists it will block any deal
that disadvantages
its fishermen but there are also big
differences over
competition rules so-called level
playing field
that could prove the hardest challenge
precisely 24 hours earlier michelle
barnier made his own journey back to
brussels
catching the same train to the same
station now
inside the european commission's
burlimon building frost and barnier will
carry the weight of trying to secure
a trade deal well the talks that are
happening here do not
involve vast battalions of negotiators
instead it's come down to michelle
barnier and lord
frost trying to finesse their entrenched
red lines and come up with a deal that's
acceptable to the british government
to the european union and also to the
european parliament now
that won't be easy and time is short but
there are plenty of diplomats who told
me
that they still expect a deal to be
announced in the coming days
but not everyone is optimistic philippe
lamberts was part of the european
parliament's brexit steering group
he told me he thinks the chances of a
deal are falling
there's really an insistence on not
making concessions that would
harm the integrity of the single market
at the last minute
just because of desperation uh for a
deal and i think
i sense that the result of the european
council is quite strong on that
likewise of the parliament brussels is a
city built on politics and
last minute deals on thursday leaders
from
across the european union will come here
for a summit
what we don't know is whether they will
be preparing for a deal
or no deal adam parsons sky news
brussels